Salut, est-ce que vous êtes déjà sûr
de pas avoir regardé cette vidéo? Genre...
Est-ce que c'est sûr et certain au fond de vous,
vous êtes sûr de ne
pas avoir vu cette vidéo?
C'est pas simple en vrai.
Ce genre de questions fait partie
des embrouilles de notre cerveau,
qui est parfois notre pire ennemi.
Il lui arrive de faire des petits bugs
qu'on n'avait pas vraiment commandés,
en fait, à l'origine.
Somnambulisme, toc,
horloge interne qui déconne, imagination...
Comment tout ça? Ça fonctionne?
Loïco, générico
...En espagnol, du coup.
Attention,
comme vous l'avez vu avec ce petit logo,
la vidéo d'aujourd'hui est sponsorisée
par NordVPN, mais vous n'en
aviez jamais entendu parler.
Il s'agit du VPN numéro 1 mondial avec 14
millions d'utilisateurs
à travers le monde.
C'est aussi le plus rapide du marché.
Disponible sur toutes les principales
plateformes en français Windows,
Android et iOS, Mac OS et même Linux.
Même, votre TV Android a son
application NordVPN... Android TV.
Ça marche dans les deux sens.
Bref, sachez qu'avec le lien Description
et mon code Fabien Olicard,
vous avez une grosse réduction
sur l'abonnement de 2 ans, plus un mois
supplémentaire en cadeau.
Merci, NordVPN.
Vérifier 6 fois si on a
bien coupé l'électricité.
3 fois si on a bien fermé la porte
d'entrée, 8 fois les interrupteurs.
On sait déjà tous demandé si on n'avait
pas un petit TOC, un trouble
obsessionnel compulsif.
Les TOC, c'est des troubles
anxieux qui se traduisent par des pensées
indésirables et récurrentes.
On appelle ça des obsessions.
Ou encore des comportements répétitifs
qui n'ont pas vraiment de sens logique,
mais qui sont très difficiles à maîtriser.
Et on appelle ça alors, des compulsions.
Il y a 2 à 3% de la population
qui en serait atteinte.
Et 50% de ces personnes seraient
handicapées au quotidien par leurs TOCs.
C'est énorme !
Les TOCs apparaissent en général entre 5
et 30 ans et peuvent être causés
par un ensemble de facteurs biologiques,
génétiques, environnementaux.
Les personnes qui en sont atteintes ont
conscience que leurs actions n'ont pas
vraiment de sens logique, mais elles
sont incapables de se contrôler.
C'est ça qui est très difficile.
Comment on peut s'en séparer?
Il y a une étude qui a montré que la prise
de caféine retarderait le moment à partir
duquel le TOC refait surface. Mais il
refait surface quand même...
Il y a une autre étude qui révèle que plus
vous vivez près de l'équateur, moins
vous avez de chances d'être atteint.
Oui, c'est juste des statistiques,
mais moi, je me dis qu'il y a,
du coup, ....Il y a deux solutions
pour éviter les TOCs :
soit on achète une bonne
cafetière, soit on déménage.
En vérité, les TOCs peuvent être traités
par des médicaments ou par une thérapie,
parfois les deux en même temps.
Dans certains cas, il y a une chirurgie
qui peut être nécessaire.
Sachez quand même que c'est une véritable
maladie et qu'il n'y a qu'un médecin qui peut
vous dire si vous êtes atteints
de troubles, vraiment de TOCs.
Quelle thérapie suivre?
Ou, quel médicament prendre?
Le somnambulisme,
c'est un trouble du sommeil qui arrive
quand votre cerveau est endormi, mais
que votre système moteur est éveillé.
En gros,
le cortex n'a pas coupé tout ce qui fait
que le cerveau contrôle le corps.
Donc, ce que vous rêvez,
vous le faites, c'est gênant.
Vous pouvez alors être amené à faire
des choses que vous ne
feriez pas en temps normal.
Parfois même des trucs hyper dangereux!
Un enfant sur cinq fait au moins
un épisode de somnambulisme
dans sa vie d'enfant.
Le problème, c'est que entre le cuistot
qui fait sa cuisine,
l'ado qui se met debout sur le rebord
de sa fenêtre, l'automobiliste qui roule
à contre sens sur l'autoroute,
l'homme qui tue ses beaux-parents
à 23 km de chez lui...
On peut dire qu'il y a
quand même des risques.
C'est des histoires vraies.
La grande question,
c'est donc :
est-ce qu'il faut réveiller
un somnambule?
Alors, si il présente pas de danger
pour lui ou pour les autres, il n'y
a aucune raison de le réveiller.
En général, l'épisode de somnambulisme,
ça dure moins de dix minutes.
Mais s'il présente un danger,
il faut alors lui suggérer d'aller se
recoucher calmement, doucement,
sans pour autant le réveiller.
Et si la situation devient vraiment
critique, faut le réveiller.
Mais sans le brusquer,
le rassurer et lui demander
de retourner au lit.
Il risque de ne
même pas s'en souvenir....
Alors, si vous vous êtes sujet
au somnambulisme, sachez que la privation
de sommeil, le stress, l'anxiété, la
fièvre, faire du sport tard le soir,
boire beaucoup avant de dormir,
la prise d'alcool ou de drogues
ou de certains médicaments sont
des facteurs aggravants
qui peuvent causer les crises.
L'hypnothérapie peut être une solution.
Il y a aussi des médicaments
et des psychothérapies qui peuvent
être prescrites dans certains cas.
Une chose est sûre si vous pensez être
dangereux pour vous ou pour les autres,
n'hésitez pas à consulter
un professionnel de la santé.
Avouez que ça, ça vous est
tous arrivé au moins une fois.
Est-ce que j'ai fermé à clé?
Où est-ce que j'ai mis mes lunettes?
Elles sont où mes clés? etc.
Ces petites choses sont rangées dans votre
mémoire épisodique à l'intérieur
de votre hippocampe.
Le truc, c'est que les neurones qu'il
contient sont renouvelés régulièrement.
Donc, l'oubli est en fait nécessaire.
Notre cerveau est bombardé d'informations
en permanence et le fait d'oublier lui
permet d'éviter la saturation et surtout
de bien trier pour retrouver
les informations importantes.
Mais on sait tous que se rendre compte
qu'on a oublié son passeport
quand on est à l'aéroport,
c'est bien relou !
Alors comment on peut faire
pour pas oublier ces trucs là?
On passe les neuf dixièmes de notre temps
dans un état qui est, pour le coup,
proche du somnambulisme, justement,
où le cerveau est en mode automatique.
Il a un vrai mode automatique.
Donc, on met les clés dans notre poche machinalement,
sans conscientiser le mouvement.
L'une des solutions,
c'est de mettre de l'affection dans ces
objets.
Un porte-clé avec une photo
de votre chat pour évoquer
une maison, par exemple.
Ou encore plus simple,
il faut porter de l'attention en se disant
son action à voix haute.
C'est à dire qu'au moment où vous fermez à clé, vous
parlez dans votre tête ou vous chuchotez,
vous dites : je ferme à clé.
S'il y a
un voisin qui passe, on a l'air chelou.
Mais le fait de le verbaliser,
alors ça porte vraiment
l'attention sur le moment présent.
Et ça, on s'en souviendra bien
dans notre mémoire épisodique.
Les petits oublis réguliers peuvent aussi
avoir d'autres causes
que la simple négligence.
Si vous en avez énormément,
posez vous des questions sur votre
état de santé mentale et mémorielle.
Si vous perdez beaucoup de choses,
c'est peut être que votre esprit
lui-même est occupé à autre chose.
Vous cachez alors peut-être du stress.
De l'anxiété, peut-être une dépression.
Toutes ces choses qui expliqueraient aussi
que vous oubliez un peu tout.
Et si vous êtes juste tête en l'air,
fournissez-vous un gadget à fixer
à ce que vous perdez le plus souvent.
Il en existe plein. Des trucs où,
quand tu siffles, le truc il te répond
et tu le retrouves, c'est pratique.
Retour du logo.
Donc, vous l'avez vu,
la vidéo d'aujourd'hui est
sponsorisée par NordVPN.
Avec NordVPN, vous pouvez élargir vos
contenus disponibles,
que ce soit sur la télé, en streaming,
mais aussi, en terme de jeux vidéo.
Mais du coup, ça sert à quoi NordVPN?
À ne plus rien oublier.
Non, c'est pour... "rien à voir"...
a surfer avec plus
de sécurité pour que vous soyez,
par exemple, sur des Wi-Fi publics, dans
un bar, à la bibliothèque, en voyage.
Vous n'ayez aucun risque, aucun danger,
mais aussi à contourner les géo-restrictions
pour profiter, comme je vous le disais,
des programmes à l'étranger depuis
chez vous, comme pour regarder
les Grands Prix de F1 sur la
chaîne nationale belge RTBF.
En vous connectant simplement, en Belgique!
Voila, c'est facile.
Ou alors des programmes français depuis
l'étranger ou même des programmes
étrangers depuis l'étranger.
Bref, tout est possible avec NordVPN.
C'est vraiment utile et encore plus
en cette saison estivale.
En passant par le lien description
ou en utilisant le code Fabien Olicard,
vous pouvez bénéficier d'un abonnement
de deux ans plus un mois supplémentaire
gratuit avec une énorme réduction.
Et en plus de ça, vous aurez un service
client français, dispo
24h sur 24, 7 jours sur 7 .
Ça fait plaisir! Avec une garantie
de remboursement de 30 jours.
Alors essayez NordVPN,
c'est sans aucun risque.
Merci NordVPN.
En vrai, merci à eux de sponsoriser cette vidéo
qui va permettre de sponsoriser
les futurs gros énormes casse-têtes
à plus de 15 ou 20.000 euros.
Vous kiffez?
Moi aussi, mais ça coûte cher.
Alors, merci NordVPN.
Est-ce que vous avez déjà eu la sensation
d'avoir vécu ce moment-là, ici,
maintenant, précisément?
Ne cherchez pas, c'est probablement
une sensation de déjà-vu.
Il se pourrait que vous ayez déjà vécu
une scène quasi-similaire, dans un endroit
qui ressemble à celui que vous découvrez
actuellement, avec les mêmes personnes
positionnées quasiment
exactement de la même manière.
Mais votre cerveau vient en fait
de vous jouer un tour.
Une étude de 2016 nous explique que lors
d'un déjà-vu,
votre cerveau viendrait d'allumer le lobe
frontal qui gère la prise de décision.
Ce qui voudrait dire que votre cerveau est
en train de vérifier s'il n'y a pas
une erreur entre
ce que vous expérimentez actuellement
et ce que vous
pensez avoir expérimenté déjà.
En bref, votre cerveau est en train
de vérifier s'il n'y a pas un bug
dans la matrice pendant que vous
vous pensez justement qu'il y en a.
En gros, c'est bon signe.
Au final, ça veut dire quand même
que votre cerveau fonctionne bien,
qu'il est en train de corriger un faux
souvenir qui était en train de se créer.
Et si vous n'avez jamais ressenti cette
sensation de déjà-vu, rassurez-vous,
vous faites partie des 30% de la population
à qui ça n'est jamais arrivé.
Et ça voudrait même dire que votre mémoire
est très performante et qu'il
n'y a pas d'erreurs à corriger.
Si ce sujet vous intéresse,
je vous laisse aussi jeter un coup d'oeil
aux excellentes vidéos d' e-penser,
qui a fait de l'excellent travail beaucoup
plus profond et précis à ce sujet.
Est-ce que vous saviez que les
tournesols suivent le soleil?
Oui, sûrement.
Ils s'orientent selon ce que leur
dicte leur horloge interne.
Eh bien, nous, on est
comme les tournesols, pareil...
...il est où le soleil?
Non,... pas tout à fait!
N'empêche que nous possédons nous
aussi notre propre horloge interne.
l'Horloge biologique,
aussi appelée l'horloge circadienne.
Ce qui définit si nous sommes plutôt du matin
ou du soir, s'appelle le chronotype.
Nous avons tous un chronotype qui dépend
de notre constitution génétique,
mais en vérité, il évolue
tout au long de notre vie.
Les enfants, par exemple,
sont plutôt du matin.
Le chronotype retarde de plus en plus
à partir du collège pour devenir
normale vers 20 ans.
Puis, plus on devient âgé,
plus on redevient matinal.
Mais chaque personne est différente
et le test de Jim Horne et Olov Ostberg...
... j'arriverai jamais à..
....à les respecter en prononçant leur nom de famille.
Donc, leur thèse vous permet
d'ailleurs de connaître votre chronotype à vous.
Le principal problème avec
l'évolution de ce chronotype,
c'est le fait qu'on dort de moins
en moins en vieillissant.
La nuit, un enfant reçoit un taux
de mélatonine, l'hormone du sommeil,
qui est alors multipliée par 20,
alors qu'une personne de 70 ans a ce même taux
qui n'est que multiplié
par trois la nuit.
La multiplication, c'est la nuit !
Et c'est la lumière du jour
qui règle notre horloge centrale.
Passer du temps dehors, plutôt
que dans un bureau, envoie des signaux
bien plus importants à notre corps.
Une lumière intense le matin et une vraie
obscurité sans écran le soir,
c'est bénéfique.
La lumière chaude permettrait d'ailleurs
de mieux préparer le corps au sommeil
plutôt que la lumière froide.
En gros, écoutez votre corps et reconnectez
vous à la lumière naturelle pour remettre
votre horloge interne à l'heure.
L'imagination,
je ne vais peut-être pas vous la définir,
mais c'est la faculté qu'on a d'évoquer
des objets ou des faits sous forme
d'images mentales, à l'intérieur de notre tête.
C'est aussi notre capacité à élaborer
des images et des conceptions nouvelles.
Mais comment ça marche,
en réalité, l'imaginaire dans notre tête?
L'image du réel va dans le cortex visuel
primaire, qui se situe à l'arrière
du cerveau, et elle est ensuite analysée
par les autres aires visuelles
qui la mettent en lien avec la mémoire.
Et bien, pour la création d'une image
mentale, c'est le chemin inverse.
Pour évoquer ou inventer un objet,
on va piocher dans les images de notre
mémoire et le cortex préfrontal active
les aires visuelles qui nous permettent de
transformer ces images dans notre tête.
La qualité de l'imagerie mentale
n'est pas la même pour tous.
On l'avait déjà vu dans une vidéo,
d'ailleurs, que je vous mettrai à la fin.
Ça, on ne peut pas y faire grand chose.
En revanche, le meilleur moyen de stimuler
votre imagination, c'est de ne rien faire.
Rien, pour de vrai.
Accordez-vous des vrais moments d'ennui,
sans téléphone, sans rien.
Votre cerveau, étonnamment, est plus
actif quand vous ne faites rien que quand
vous effectuez certaines tâches.
La lecture aussi stimule l'imaginaire.
Votre cerveau se nourrit d'images que vous
créez au fur et à mesure de votre
lecture de votre roman, par exemple.
Les données que vous lisez sont alors
mises en lien avec la bibliothèque
d'images mentales déjà présentes
dans votre cerveau pour en créer
des nouvelles qui sortent que de vous!
Pour info, si vous n'avez pas d'imagerie mentale,
il se peut que vous soyez aphantasique.
Je remettrai la vidéo à la fin où j'en
parlais. Mais renseignez vous sur le sujet.
C'est très intéressant d'en prendre
conscience, quand on l'est.
Bon, rassurez-vous, votre
cerveau est extraordinaire.
Vraiment, soyez en fiers.
J'en suis certain.
J'ai écrit deux livres qui portent ce nom.
Donc, c'est sûr.
Et comme vous l'avez vu,
il est aussi capable de faire un tas
de choses sans que vous
ayez à le lui demander.
Que vous soyez somnambule, que vous ayez
des TOCs ou que votre horloge interne soit...
soit un peu déréglée.
Certes, votre cerveau vous joue des tours,
mais il y a toujours une chance
pour que vous réussissiez
à le retourner à votre avantage.
Merci encore une fois NordVPN d'avoir
sponsorisé cette vidéo et de
soutenir la chaîne, grâce à ça,
pour les plus gros projets.
Téléchargez-le en passant par mon lien
dans la description et profitez d'un mois
d'abonnement gratuit.
Moi,
je m'appelle toujours Fabian Olicard.
Merci d'avoir regardé cette vidéo.
Vous pouvez vous abonner en cliquant ici.
C'est gratuit.
Faites-le, si n'est pas déjà fait, parce
qu'on s'approche des 2 millions.
Et ça, c'est un peu fou quand même!
Activez la cloche pour ne pas
rater les prochaines vidéos.
Donc ici, la vidéo où je
parlais de la fantaisie.
Et si une autre vidéo,
mais plutôt sur des expériences stylées
sur le cerveau.
Prenez-soin de vous!
A très bientôt.
Tchao!